creativity matters everywhere if you're
running for mayor in your you know town
or if you're running coca-cola um hi
everyone here we are in can and I am
with the incredible Gary Vaynerchuk I am
so excited we've been trying to do this
for the longest longest time at a time
and he's rocked up today in a Spurs kit
which my kids are absolutely going to
love everything he knows everything
about you you are a serial entrepreneur
you set up that first business and
lemonade business age seven now chairman
of aina
AG CEO of ad agency Romania and we're
actually going to talk today about
authenticity and how brands can create
real and meaningful connections with
consumers and I'm hoping you're gonna
share some of your top tips today so
welcome to the Facebook space thank you
for coming thanks for having me so let's
get straight in so tell me let's we're
talking about authenticity in a brand
what does it mean to you from a brand
communication you know it's this is an
interesting question I had a very pretty
for this world a pretty left-field point
of view on this and my point of view is
that we need to achieve relevance I'm
looking at 11 12 13 faces right now and
what Pepsi or BMW or coca-cola or
Facebook means to all these people is
actually different and so for me
authenticity gets very close to
relevancy because when you're a big
brand there are so many variables in
your world there's so many things that
you're doing you know some people may
drink a cola to get a burst of energy
others it may be a reminder of spending
time with their grandmother and I think
we're so literal in today's brand and
marketing world we're so stuck on
sentences and adjectives and we spend so
much time on subjective things that
don't matter to the consumer on the
other end so my perspective is much like
a human being
you and I are gonna act differently
right now as humans in this interview
then if we were with our family then if
we were on a weekend in Las Vegas with
our best friends then if we were
presenting to 5,000 people people always
like Gary you're a little bit different
than when you I see you on video I'm
like yeah I'm on stage to 7,000 people
versus I'm here with you there's
different versions and I think people
struggle in
I'd land to understand things are
multi-dimensional and so for me
authenticity is actually being
comfortable in the 74 to 74 hundred
variations of how you show up and so I
think that we are that human beings
executives are limiting brands ability
to be authentic because they want it to
be so literal and so safe and so peered
and so approved by the queen bee that uh
that I think we live in a very non
authentic world and I think the reason
humans continue to scale in popularity
is there a focus group of the audience
they're there they're an executive group
of one and I think one of the reasons
real celebrities are struggling and have
lost share is they do have PR people
they do have big deals with movie
studios that they're scared of breaking
and so I think anyone who could actually
show all the versions of themselves will
win and I think right now the creative
industry a isn't set up to make enough
creative be has way too much b2b DNA in
it to actually show up authentic and
this is not schizophrenia this is not
throw up against a wall and see what
sticks this is not being scattered this
is being true and so I think
authenticity has a farm or at its end
there's always a something that delivers
at the end a piece of content or
creative and I think it's being far more
wide than it's been over the last 80
years so who's doing it well which
brands would you point to guys nailed it
one of the things that I don't do very
well is pay attention to what other
people are doing okay so this is always
a tough question for me there is
something that's you know I thought
Wendy's did a really good job over the
last couple years of engaging at scale
which then led to a voice that gave them
a lot of freedom but the reality is I
know what's going on in the Vayner world
obviously I know what's going on in the
broad sense but I spent almost no time
auditing what other brands are doing m+
if we're talking from a brand standpoint
well has to be reflected in business
results there's a ton of people that are
gonna win awards today
that business is declining dramatically
and I struggle with that because the
point of that creativity is to drive a
business result in this context or get
people to vote or inspire a movement or
cure a disease like what's the point of
output if you're not getting the end
result and so you know I don't know
who's doing it well I would say
whoever's doing it well is definitely
has business results and definitely has
a breadth of execution so you've been
with businesses and you've taken
businesses from you know very small to
very big do you think this different
stages where authenticity and creative
matters more no I think it always
matters as a matter of fact what right
now watching everybody pay attention to
all the sound behind us and they're like
to me and this is not a joke this is
very meta I have so much empathy
especially as d-roc and producers in my
world have come into my world the amount
of empathy I have for people that are
incredible at their skill set and what
they think about is so important to me
at the same token I genuinely live in a
world where I think the person that's
consuming this on the other side kind of
enjoys the helicopter or the the boat or
like the the microphone because it's
real and and not it's not that my point
of view is right or where production
companies points of view are right or
wrong I just think that I'm fascinated
by this notion and we're living in the
meta of it right now first of all to
answer the question directly because I
wanted to clearly make that point
creativity matters everywhere if you're
running for mayor in your you know town
or if you're running coca-cola and I and
I think if you look at what's happening
look there's a lot of politicians I
desperately don't agree with but in
their authenticity of being crappy they
get an audience and I think we have to
learn from that across the board
now earlier this year you set up another
new business the fashion group all
focused on small business now what what
one piece of advice would you give to a
small business out there that's looking
to find its voice or its personality
that's a great question uh lean into
your founder whether she or he is
introverted or extroverted because they
either are extroverted and charismatic
enough to drive your business and your
small company and you need something or
they're introverted but they actually
know their craft very well and though
they may not be the most dynamic on film
they may be incredible in podcast form
educating people how to do refrigeration
or how to sell tires or whatever it may
be so lean into your founder and make as
much creative output as you can for the
platforms that are dominating the mobile
device the Facebook and instagrams the
snapchats linkedin's the youtubes of the
world is where the world is now playing
and making content and written audio or
video form for those platforms is
imperative for an SMB we were getting
tens of thousands of enquiries at
vaynermedia from SMBs and we couldn't
take them on because we're too expensive
for them because the business I built
was to service big brands but I came
from SMB and I almost felt almost like a
hypocrite slash you know the reason I
named it directly after my dad Sasha is
cuz that's my roots and I thought we
were ready to help that world and it's
been very I would I would tell you
honestly it's been far more fulfilling
helping these small companies there's a
nail nail business in Toronto that was
in deep deep deep trouble because their
main distributor was about to like they
thought they might cancel them and sure
enough in your later they did but we
helped them build a direct-to-consumer
business through leading it to their
founder I mean I'm I give advice that
actually i watch happen we leaned into
the founder we made a ton of Instagram
Facebook Twitter content and the
business is up three acts in revenue yet
that are said I lived it taking my dad's
business from three mil four million to
sixty million do you know what how
life-changing that is for a business I
bought my car at a garage sale for five
hundred bucks my brother got a Lexus
like it changes when you build a
business like that so like you know
we're doing incredible work with Chase
and Budweiser and all this great stuff
but when you're helping an SMB and look
let's call it what it is being at the
Facebook million my point of view from
the outside the small and medium-sized
businesses of the world have figured out
Facebook far
far more than the biggest brands in the
world cuz the biggest brands in the
world deal with audacity and fake and SM
B's can only live in the truth because
if they live in fake they go out of
business
okay so any favorite but you've
mentioned a few any favorite platforms
or tools that are really good for
helping these businesses to build their
connections podcast YouTube Facebook
Twitter Instagram snapchat LinkedIn has
exploded in the last six months
LinkedIn acts like Facebook did six
seven years ago organic reach on
LinkedIn is shocking so there's that
Instagram story ads is the most under
priced ad in the world buying Instagram
swipe up story ads that take you exactly
to where we want you to go for two to
three or four dollars CPM and they're
actually being seen unheard of so those
are some of the things I'm excited okay
what about your own channels you're your
own podcast yeah it's go Harry how are
you learning to expert now not that I
think you have any troubles with this
but how do you think you're learning or
tips that you can give about how you
express yourself personally and what
you've able therefore to be able to
transfer into the brands that which you
communicate for look the single thing
I'm most proud of sitting a can is
there's not a human here not one that
makes more creative output that I do on
a daily basis and collective period that
is an audacious but factual statement
there's not one person here that makes
more content than I do and I'm a CEO of
a company not a creative and in that you
can imagine in a world where me and my
team are producing 40 to 100 pieces of
content a day across all these platforms
there's a practitioner ship that allows
me I mean the amount of mistakes you
know it's fun to have d rockier cuz he's
on the text chain with me and my team we
change our mind seven times a month I
constantly [ __ ] on my own self once a
week like I emphatically on Monday say
it's all about this and literally next
Tuesday go if we ever do that again
we're fit I mean this is real life this
is the truth and they are testing and
learning with yourselves that's at a
scale that is unseen
right now and should be replicated by
everyone which gives me much better
insights to what the consumers reacting
to and then obviously I'm a human with a
certain kind of flavor so that doesn't
map to dub the same exact way
so there's macro things we see that we
deploy and then we see how it plays out
it's never literal for me to I'm a human
I'm a forty three old man there's a lot
of things that don't navigate but
there's a lot of the truths that we
navigate that we test and learn there
and that we scale so it is the ultimate
test lab okay so you a few bold
statements there but I can say you are
the only person in all these and I've
interviewed a lot of people that has
ever walked in with your own microphone
because you're literally just logging
and recording and observing the whole
time and listen when I hear that
sentence my brain goes to charlatans
self-promoter like audacious I mean that
and and I'm saying that because I want
the audience to understand when you're
innovating you're gonna be misunderstood
like when we decided three and a half
years ago to film everything I knew that
that wasn't gonna be so easy to navigate
life I mean this is at least this
setting is somewhat normal how about in
your normal day-to-day when you're just
going to a normal meeting and you're
being filmed like people are gonna cast
judgment and I don't want to come across
that way it's just that the value of
content at scale is the cost of entry
for success in my opinion of this next
decade and yeah that's why we do it so
you have famously predicted many trends
that have come true so we couldn't be
here with the helicopters planes boats
going on what are the next big trends
that you're looking at I think that
alexa and google home is going to be a
major major factor over the next decade
and I implore since we're here for I
always think sucks has some secret lab
when he's working on this because I
can't imagine Facebook not entering this
for a the attention of the end consumer
is everything you've tried portal yes I
have I have you're right I have and to
that point that's that's a solid counter
I think that voice-activated
decision-making is going to be a big
deal because consumers care so little
about privacy and so much about saving
time
and nothing saves you more time than
sitting in your living room deciding you
want to go to a movie and it is far
faster for me to say Alexa portal Google
home whatever Microsoft Scott and
whatever some Chinese companies got
Alexa what movies are playing that is
faster than grabbing your phone and
searching Fandango and in that speed and
getting your answers will be enormous
disruption over the next decade so I'm
extremely bullish on voice-activated
devices okay we're out of time you've
got a million places you've got to go to
but we have a Facebook tradition of the
quick fire round don't overthink it just
say do you guys normally play awesome
music right now do you post produce that
way you'll know rice producer dad
another one firing fireworks in the
building in the background so first one
can or California canned okay I really
don't like California I love California
social point of view in the world
yeah yeah American football or baseball
American football okay Tottenham Hotspur
Tottenham Hotspur both okay cardio or
weight cardio
okay podcast or vlog Oh
you just literally asked me like which
child do I love yes by the way real
quick on that every parent has a
favorite child
this is this is absolutely true you're
gonna kill me with my folders and apps
not true for Katherine I promise you you
may not want to know this but your mom
definitely has a favorite I'm sure all
four of you actually know who it is
like for example in my family everyone
knows it's me I will go with podcast
I like making decisions I think that
audio is passive consumption and I feel
like even a lot of people who watch my
vlog actually only watch it with the
audio while they're driving working out
so I will go with we are in the rise of
the next decade of audio because we've
gotten faster technology is caught up we
want to consume information but having
to pay attention to the video versus
listening while I do something else not
as valuable okay and just for the record
Gaby died me Sam and Zak I love you all
equally don't listen to them it's final
very important question Cola or lemonade
you know what's a drink Cola and this is
funny with a lemon in it I only don't
think it's not cheating it's what's
amazing about what you actually let me
be even more transparent the I've
stopped drinking Cola as much over the
last five years but I've kind of reap
icked it up in the last six months
because I missed it I only drink Cola
with lemon and lime minutes only
I actually dislike right so much so I
don't like regular Cola anymore I fresh
lemon lime not when they spice it like I
need to do it like they're little pieces
and then I like bite the actual lemon
and like eat the whole like peal and
everyone freaks out it's like a whole to
do is to be they don't overthink it most
people just gonna Cola or lemon it's not
Gary's one message that I take out more
than anything is experiment experiment
try it don't don't be afraid be more
authentic more creative things will
happen and crucially more business
results will come thank you for being
with us actually have really appreciated
you